más romeros alaya hoy es viernes y
estamos listos para bailar este nuevo
disco de agua y todas sus canciones que
tanto nos gustan pero primero hablemos
de salud vamos a dedicar todo nuestro
espacio de salud para hablar de la
malaria porque mañana se celebra el día
de la lucha contra esta enfermedad en el
continente americano omar así así es
mañana desde ese día hoy no mañana no
trabajamos entonces toca hablarlo hoy
porque como dice sabremos bailado agua
este esta noche tengo descansando mañana
exacto exacto pero bueno hablemos
hablemos de cosas más importantes la
verdad es que la malaria se concentra
principalmente en el continente africano
tenemos que empezar diciendo esto más
del 90% de los casos suceden ahí pero
eso no significa que no siga siendo un
problema en la región donde hay varios
países que siguen sufriendo esta
enfermedad en los últimos años se han
logrado avances gigantescos en la lucha
contra la malaria es muy importante que
destaquemos esto desde 2000 desde el año
2000 los casos han caído en un 40%
900.000 casos aproximadamente se
diagnosticaron en 2019 y la incidencia
que nos habla de los casos nuevos que se
diagnostican también en este periodo de
tiempo también ha caído en un
57% son buenas noticias que nos hablan
de una reducción de que las herramientas
y las estrategias de la lucha contra la
enfermedad han funcionado pero que sin
embargo tenemos que reconocer que en los
últimos años se ha estancado un poco y
más con la pandemia de kobe 19 que ha
devuelto ciertas enfermedades a la
sombra raúl la malaria es
definitivamente una de ellas así es
marilyn nosotros le pregunto cuáles son
los países más afectados por esta
enfermedad en nuestro en nuestra región
en américa latina' si quieren empecemos
por una buena noticia y es que son tres
los países que se declararon libres de
malaria en los últimos años por la
organización panamericana de la salud el
primero es paraguay y el segundo de
argentina y en este año 2021 el salvador
pero siempre hay una cara negativa de la
moneda y es que como ven en el gráfico
venezuela es el país con más casos de
malaria ahora profundizaremos en la
situación en este país y lo sigue en
brasil y colombia entre estos tres
países suman el 86 por ciento de los
casos de malaria en toda la región en
todo el continente americano de hecho
entonces pues como ves hay buenas
noticias pero también hay malas noticias
al menos noticias que nos tienen que
alarmar un claro que alarman mar por
supuesto venezuela quería cuáles son los
factores que explican el aumento en la
malaria en ese país pues sabemos hemos
hablado largo y tendido en este programa
y en frank 34 de la crisis que afecta a
venezuela económica social en todos los
sentidos y eso pues por supuesto tiene
una consecuencia sobre la salud de las
personas una de ellas es en el
crecimiento de enfermedades que
previamente estaban un poquito o cerca
de la erradicación y repasemos las
cifras del 70 por ciento de las muertes
de malaria en todo el continente
americano sucedieron en venezuela en el
2019 una cifra muy desproporcionada y
mientras veíamos que los casos se habían
reducido en américa latina en un 40% en
venezuela se han multiplicado en el
mismo periodo de tiempo entre el 2010
2019 por 13 o se han aumentado muy
significativamente
precisamente de eso hablamos con el
doctor alfonso rodríguez morales ex
presidente de la asociación colombiana
de infectología y nos dio algunas de las
claves que explican este crecimiento
el par de emergencia de la malaria que
no es una sorpresa porque obviamente
entra dentro de un contexto en el cual
han caído los programas de control de
muchas enfermedades la noche antimalaria
que al control vectorial el diagnóstico
temprano y el tratamiento oportuno
todo eso lamentablemente es un círculo
vicioso en el cual la malaria tiene la
oportunidad de resurgir de la manera no
solamente muy considerable para el país
sino de nuevo también me dan casos
importados el nombre para visitar la
región
esos otros países de la región por
ejemplo nos comentaba el doctor son
argentinas han detectado casos de
malaria importados desde venezuela y
también es importante destacar algo que
nos comentaba el mismo doctor que es que
la minería ilegal en la frontera con
brasil está por ejemplo aumentando esta
crisis sanitaria en el país porque hace
que las personas entren más en contacto
con los reservorios de mosquitos que
transmiten esta enfermedad como hemos
hablado también en esta crónica el clima
no sólo afecta pues el cambio climático
y la emergencia sino también nuestra
propia salud claro y si está
desbalanceado la biodiversidad pues por
supuesto todo está muy mal mar vamos
ahora con la organización mundial de la
salud hablando de este tema porque
recomiendo propio grave es una vacuna
contra la malaria le pregunto qué
impacto batería esta vacuna en nuestra
región américa latina' fue una gran
noticia cuando salió y no podemos dejar
de abal de hablar de ello tenemos que
retroceder un poco explicando que la
malaria es una enfermedad infecciosa
provocada por cinco parásitos y que se
transmite a través de los mosquitos la
vacuna desarrollada y recientemente
apoyada por la organización mundial de
la salud lucha contra uno de esos
parásitos uno de los cinco el plasmodium
falciparum ese parásito es el que es
predominante en áfrica y es el que causa
más muertes y más casos de malaria en
todo el mundo pero en américa latina' no
es el parásito predominante aquí es el
plasmodium vivax el que crea el 75 por
ciento de casos de malaria eso significa
que el impacto de la vacuna podría ser
algo más limitado en nuestra región
porque precisamente no lucha contra ese
parásito pero para entender mejor qué
impacto podría tener también se lo
preguntamos por supuesto al doctor
alfonso rodríguez
la vacuna va a tener una utilidad para
dudas también en américa latina en el
momento en que éste empiece a ser usada
acá porque la vacuna para participar nos
va a servir para ciertas zonas donde
dentro de américa latina hay una
importante presencia hay una importante
circulación de este parásito pero a la
vez es importante mencionar que por
ejemplo de países como colombia se está
trabajando grupos muy serios en el país
comandante destructor sócrates herrera
en el desarrollo de vacunas
específicamente para el caso de la vida
siempre es bueno terminar con una nota
de optimismo también hay otras vacunas
que están siendo investigadas también en
américa latina particularmente para
luchar contra la malaria en la región
entonces como siempre estaremos
pendientes de cómo se desarrollan estas
investigaciones raúl así es marc y bueno